so we've heard rumors there was local
reporting from independent outlets that
they called tow companies and the
companies like look we're not getting
involved in this we we don't want to you
know tow these trucks because we work
with them and things like that but now
we have the cbc and the government
acknowledging towing companies on city
contracts even are refusing to move
convoy vehicles you're going to love
this look at this
according to
canelo cos mayor jim watson has reached
out to his counterparts and other
ontario municipalities but no dice no
one wants to help right now the
consensus seems to be that many of them
or most of them don't want to do the
work because they rely on the heavy
truck industry for their livelihood and
they don't want to damage that part of
their business that's the position
they're taking at least
deputy police chief steve bell agreed
that finding companies that will agree
to tow protesters has been a challenge
in quote every jurisdiction that's faced
this and it's forcing us to come up with
some creative solutions he wouldn't
elaborate on what those creative
solutions might be but said police are
coming quote toward a position where
we're not going to let the tow truck
operators be an obstacle to ending
what's occurring i just want you to
think about that last quote for one
quick second
what does that mean they're an obstacle
oh you've gone to a private company and
said i require your service and they
said good day sir and you said you are
now an obstacle to me ending a protest
what are they going to do steal the tow
trucks and operate them themselves
they're not going to know how to do it
could you imagine some cop being like
let me just figure this thing out i
think i can get it they'd have to steal
the vehicles commandeer these companies
because the companies won't do it it's
it's very difficult to tow trucks when
the tow trucks won't tow trucks
well there's also a quote from uh
local trucker who laughed at the
prospect when they someone asked him are
you worried about getting towed and he
said anybody who's worked with these big
rigs know knows that when you activate
the air brakes these things cannot move
unless the operator wants them to move
so the tow truck drivers are like
that's one of the other stories we have
they're basically saying removing trucks
well they're literally saying would be
almost impossible
it's a gridlock think about it this way
too
you've got you know let's say you have
four by four trucks in the road how are
you going to be able to tow one of the
trucks one at a time and try and clear
it out it's it's insane they're heavy
duty the companies won't do it and even
if they could these trucks have
basically gridlocked the area they're
smaller cars it's i'll say this
physically possible
logistically impossible yeah moving all
these cars to get to the trucks and then
clear everything out it's never going to
happen
yeah not without not without the
cooperation of the tow truck companies
who can give you the expertise necessary
not without some amount of meaningful
coercion that you can enforce i mean
think about if you had an individual
tow truck
or an individual trucker who was pulling
a stunt like this okay you could
probably figure out how to do it if you
find one tow truck you could be like
also like we're gonna throw you in jail
for a long time unless you help us the
longer you wait the worse it'll be for
you um but when when you've got like a
mass protest like this where the tow
trucks are you know it's just they're in
an impossible situation yeah one of the
things i love so much about this is that
there have been so many instances in
this country of specific special
interest groups with a lot of money in
power who are very cunning trying to
resist specific policies and not being
able to
and then you have these truckers who
band together and no one can do anything
about it it's really incredible well the
crazy thing is the solidarity i guess
it's the truckers took action and the
tow truck drivers were like nah nah we
work with these guys we're not getting
involved
they can offer up the cops everything in
the world apparently ottawa police are
exempt from the vaccine mandates they
give them special privileges in the cops
with a smile on their face put the boot
on your neck
but when it comes to the industry of
truckers too many people rely on them
imagine it this way too
it's not just tow truck drivers there's
probably a supermarket and the cops are
gonna be like don't you provide service
to these truckers they're gonna be like
i don't want to get involved because if
i start making these guys angry they
don't deliver to my store anymore i got
to work with these guys man yeah if the
truckers boycott a grocery store chain
that chain's in trouble yeah no well
that's that's what i'm saying that's
what i love about this so much is that
it has to be unbelievably frustrating to
them because the government has been
able to push around
literally everybody
and you look at all the incredibly
powerful people who cower at the face of
policies and uh you know try to resist
them but are unable and then you just
have truckers banding together and
people standing in solidarity with them
and the political class is unable to do
anything about it kind of like an immune
system like it's a natural emergence of
the system is it's it it rises up and
defends itself
it wipes out any kind of ill you know it
it that's what it seems like it seems
like
well the truckers are like the red blood
cells of the body but now these chakras
are acting like white blood cells
weeding out a dangerous corruption
macrophages i guess
i guess what i'm really trying to say
here is there's an incredibly valuable
lesson in all of this because
it wasn't a think tank uh it wasn't a
political interest organization it
wasn't any group of intellectuals that
banded together to resist resist this
policy and push back against it like it
was literally just ordinary people it's
like a snooty rich kid on the playground
who's bullying people because he's
allowed to do whatever he wants and then
there's some just like regular
working-class kid who minds his own
business and everyone's always getting
picked on by the snooty rich kid and
then everyone's just like i wish he
would stop and then one day the regular
kid who's just like he just gets up and
he's a bigger dude and he just shoves
the this new little kid to the ground
he's like you can't do that don't you
know i'm gonna go shut up yeah
it's just like you finally pushed the
quiet guy he's had enough of your bs and
there's nothing you can do except comply
just comply is it so hard you can go
back to normal if you just comply well i
think justin trudeau was saying that the
only way to get wait what how oh i got
to get his quote you guys the only way
to stop removing our our rights is to
remove some more rights really quick i
don't know what he said
a yeah sympathetic to the left on this
if they hadn't spent two years
justifying every type of lawless
disturbance and riot over their own pet
cause exactly you know like as a general
matter i want to be in the position
where i'm saying no riots are bad obey
the law whatever but i'm sorry you guys
spent two years blocking traffic over
you know extinction rebellion and justin
trudeau rooting it on and all this
nonsense and i'm like take some of your
own medicine the the riot so i'm not i'm
not familiar how bad riots got in canada
if at all i don't know i don't pay
attention to canada all that much to be
honest a little bit and this story is
particularly big so you know we are we
are seeing it
with as it goes to the cultural left you
know these guys
are engaging in
possibly the most peaceful protest you
could ever engage in
the roads are shut down there's no risk
to someone getting run over remember
when blm went in the highway and were
like dancing around in the car like
swerved and hit people like that's
dangerous they've shut down
downtown streets so
there's no traffic it's way safer uh it
doesn't it doesn't isn't like false
imprisonment the way that sort of
standing in traffic to like block just
average everyday people is well they've
they've not taken any police stations
like jazz they're not riots these are
protests i mean they're not attacking
cars there's a bit of a private nuisance
so i don't know if you guys are familiar
with nuisance law so nuisance can take
any number of forms like say you have a
plant that's putting out nasty chemicals
into the air the people who live around
you have a claim in torque for nuisance
right you're not allowed if you if
you're damaging everybody around use
property then and and that's uh that's a
nuisance so and nuisance can be noise
too right like obnoxious noise pollution
in the middle of the night is not lawful
um in general so like i get you know i
get again so i get a little bit of where
they're coming from but i'm just under
the circumstances in canada sorry no you
get to deal with this until you repeal
the mandates because
you decided to let your people run wild
wait do way worse things i'm fine with
civil disobedience that breaks laws
when extinction rebellion blocked the
roads that boat in dc i think it was i
said hey you know what more power to
them honestly they're gonna have to come
in they're gonna have to remove those
the boat they're gonna have to arrest
everybody the people will get arrested
they will get charged it's not the most
egregious charge they'll ever face in
the world but they didn't get violent
they made their point and they got
arrested for it that's kind of like the
middle ground where we're like well we
don't want people to always be doing
things like this but we tolerate a
certain degree of civil disobedience
when people want to get their voice
heard truckers are doing just that i'll
defend that all the same but when blm
and antifa go around smashing windows
and burning buildings down nobody agrees
with that that's you you've gone so far
over the line we're like dude stop
you're crazy you're crazy people yeah
it's contextual if there was a purpose
for that like in a war scenario you do
do that to preserve yourself you have to
like fight but the context didn't seem
right for the riots it seemed out of
context and this does seem in context in
canada and it's also specific to a very
narrow ask i think that's another reason
it's substantially more virtuous right
like black lives matter what are they
asking for like end systemic racism what
does that even mean and how do you how
do you verify it's done how do you know
it's just like an endless ask for
whatever words these guys are like
repeal this
executive order right now once we'll go
home the moment you do and they're not
asking for a gain right so so blm people
are like we have a list of demands of
things you have to give us the truckers
are like you did something we didn't
like and we're asking you to stop yeah
i'm like they're not even asking you for
anything dude they're like you did thing
stop doing thing yeah they're the
truckers are coming from a negative
position and trying to return to zero
whereas blm was starting from zero and
trying to jump up in other positions now
don't get me wrong police brutality is
bad and protesting police brutality is a
good thing those people who are
protesting police brutality are coming
from a negative and they're saying we
want to go back to zero where we have a
right to live peacefully and have our
rights respected but when blm comes out
and says we want funding for this
program in louisville they demanded a
cut of of local business revenue i'm
like that mafia
exactly that's the incentive and then
they went to a cuban restaurant and they
smashed a potted plant like give us what
we want he was like no and they smashed
a pot it's like dude that's like my
behavior so let me just stress when i
see blm marching down the street and
they're doing their communist fist and
all that i'm like i really disagree with
them but i understand if it's a peaceful
protest if it's non-violence of
disobedience yeah more power to you man
we got we got to tolerate some degree of
civil unrest but we have a hard line we
have a soft line in a hard line
with these truckers they're just
basically like
stop ruling by decree it violates the
law please please stop breaking the law
yeah i'm okay with all of it yeah
absolutely well we were even talking
about this the other day with jb
pritzker giving 300 000
of federal coveted relief money to blm
and one thing i said at that point was
blm is the perfect scam because there
aren't any actual results you have to
show for it like you mentioned a moment
ago the goals are very nebulous and
they'll talk about systemic racism and
we want this change in that change but
it's never anything really concrete
whereas these truckers are again they're
asking for something very solid they're
saying repeal this law don't force me to
take an injection that i don't want and
on top of it they're not starting this
massive trucker organization called like
trucker lives matter where they're
asking for millions of dollars millions
of dollars in getting funding from state
authorities and then spending it on
mansions
we'll see yeah we will see to be fair
it remains to be seen yeah it might be a
missed opportunity would be yeah yeah
no hold on look end systemic anti-truck
discrimination exactly i i don't have a
problem with the with the uh the
function of black lives matter starting
a global organization and raising money
i have a problem with authoritarianism i
have a problem with the authoritarian
application of their ideologies i have a
personal disagreement with their
ideologies that should be debated but
their tactics don't allow for a
reasonable debate so they're playing
they're playing an unreasonable game
with an unreasonable ideology i don't
care if any organization wants to raise
money no if the truckers launch the you
know truckers for freedom or whatever
and they end up raising 60 million
dollars that's fantastic if truckers for
freedom raises 60 million dollars and it
turns out their address is fake and
there's no leader and no knows where the
money is i'm gonna have a problem with
that no exactly i have zero problem with
global organizations trying to raise
money right i mean i'm catholic but
when you look at blm specifically if you
look at blm specifically
it's the not the fact they're trying to
raise money it's again they're trying to
raise money for nebulous goals and at
the end of the day
they don't have to show any results
that's what's so frightening about it
there's literally nothing that the money
actually goes towards other than we want
to hire a diversity officer here or we
want to give a payout to this group well
to be fair that that louisville group
specifically would have to net 15
percent of the local businesses revenue
to show results because that's what they
were going for so at least as evil as
their plan was it was tangible you know
they're like guys guys we're raising
money to shake down local businesses for
a cut of their revenue yeah well to go
towards our ideology and i again i was
being i was being like a little
tongue-in-cheek about the catholic thing
earlier but no i mean the catholic
church is one of the number one
charitable givers i think you can have
an organization that raises a lot of
money and is uh
global that does good and if blm did
good i would have zero problem with what
they were doing but we want to destroy
the family and they're trying to usher
in socialism thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 pm don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel and if you want more unfiltered
and uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you